all right let's go to the phones we have
people that want to chat we are doing an
early Friday show I guess we're calling
it because of the Thanksgiving holiday
so we'll go right to the phones and see
what people have to say our phone number
is six one seven eight three zero
4750 we'll go to our first caller from
the eight four five area code
caller from eight four five introduce
yourself tell me what's on your mind
today
hello great I'm a big fan of your show
awesome what's going on and this is
probably gonna be a big complex but here
I go
you know how you write on the you know
the Hillary facility Clinton they're
Russian collisions are you calling from
a wind tunnel mark I'm kind of calling
outside okay is it safe for you to be
out because it sounds like there's a
tornado or fighter jet near that one
it's New York okay aren't good there's
no data okay so uh who's in Russia
Hillary yeah what's your question yeah I
know that um both sides of the fence
from dick Hillary kind of a dick that's
why I did well for you know you write it
on the boat from both sides I'm that
kind of guy and I want your thoughts on
the on the idea of a bunch of planned
smear campaigns both sides are on both
sides and your thoughts on how they go
about that the second question is about
the man with less so let's focus on
first question first because I don't
understand it you're saying what's my
opinion on hypothetical smear campaigns
done by who and again no no both of
their smear notes are both both of their
current current snail campaigns it's on
a bit out of left there you go you're
saying Trump and Hillary are smearing
each other now well they've been
smearing each other from the beginning
yeah it's a we know how
nobody's gaining anything from Trump
continued the election was over a year
ago why is Trump sniffing about Hillary
why but um you know how you know you
rile up people's emotions by uh by
saying oh this person did that this
person did this and pointing out those
small obvious things that like like for
example the grabbing of the piece yeah
or the Hillary Iranian one or you know
those those ratings that keeps going
back and forth making it hard to
actually look into these situations one
by one in a appropriate matter yes Ted
hyping up both sides as they as both
sides split apart sorry doesn't get me
complicated and alright listen I
apologize but I don't want to be rude
but I don't understand any of the
questions I'm really sorry let's chock
it up to the windy here let's chalk it
up to the white I really appreciate the
call and be safe there in New York if
someone can interpret what the question
was by all means please please do